Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
in the final of the six points that he
taught the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam
as the first building blocks to his
character and his dawa.
When he revealed to him the verses of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says to him,
"Stand and warn
and your Lord exalt
and your own clothing purify and purify
your deeds and fulfill your oath.
and
abandon
the
idols. Abandon all of idolatry.
Abandon the idols and abandon all that
will end with the punishment of Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
And do not reproach.
Do not reproach upon your followers. Do
not reproach your followers for what you
do for them. And do not reproach your
Lord for what you do in his service.
And for your Lord's sake, be patient.
These are not only the building blocks
of
his da sall. Wasam. These are the
essence. This is the essence of Islam.
When the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
was asked by Gabriel
very famous narration of
he came to him and asked what is Islam?
Islam.
He said Islam is to testify that none is
rightfully worshiped but Allah and that
Muhammad is the messenger of Allah. To
establish prayer to give zakah to fast
Ramadan and to make your migration or
your hajj to the house of Allah if you
are able to do so.
He defined Islam
by its most prominent rights.
by its most prominent rights. By its
most prominent pillars. This is why
they're referred to as the pillars of
Islam.
These are the most prominent aspects,
rights, and practices of Islam.
So he identified it by its parts.
But if we were to ask what is the
definition of Islam?
The definition of Islam that every
prophet and messenger came to his people
with. We know the prophets and
messengers they all have the same
religion.
There is no difference in the core
essence of their religion.
The prophet Sam
said,
he said, "We the prophets
are
paternal brothers." Notice the wording,
paternal brothers.
[Silence]
forchech.
He says, "Sallam,
we the prophets are paternal brothers."
What are paternal brothers?
Physically speaking, paternal brothers
are siblings that have different mothers
but all have the same father.
This is a figurative that he is speaking
about a spiritual brotherhood. He says
we the prophets are paternal brothers.
Our mothers vary yet our religion is
one. He didn't say our father is one. He
said our religion is one.
Meaning that the core religion of Islam,
Islam
is the religion of all the prophets and
messengers.
Even if they have subtle differences in
the nuances of their laws, halal haram,
the expression of that worship may vary
based on what is appropriate for the
time and place and people. However,
their religion is one. They were all
Muslim.
And so if we were to say, what is that
religion of theirs? Define it. What is
the definition of Islam?
The definition of Islam is
[Silence]
these are the three points that define
Islam. What is the definition of Islam?
person were to say what is Islam?
You define it as what its actual
substance is. What is it based on? It is
the first pointed
submission to Allah withhed.
The belief in Allah alone without any
partners. The worship of Allah alone
without any partners.
The second point
and obedience to him or we should say
submission to him with in obedience
and
disassociation
from Shik and its people.
This is the definition of Islam.
The definition of Islam
number one, it is submission to Allah
with
and submission to him in obedience.
and disassociation
from shik
and its people.
These three points have to unite in a
single person for the person to be
Muslim.
For instance, a person who enters into
Islam but enters
worshshiping other than Allah. Others
along with Allah, this person cannot be
Muslim.
A person enters into Islam but they do
not obey him, obey Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala at all. What do we mean by
obedience? A general holistic obedience
meaning the person
his or her attitude is Allah is my
creator I have to obey him I have to
obey Allah and his messenger it has some
bearing on the person's life even if it
is slight even if it is very weak at its
beginning
and those two will not be accepted until
a person thirdly
rejects and disassociates himself from
shik and its people.
Notice the wording shik and its people.
Disassociation
meaning a religious disassociation.
doesn't mean you wouldn't have a shik
a neighbor that's a mushri or a boss
that's a mushri or a parent that's a
mushri whatever the case may be these
are cultural
associations we are speaking about a
spiritual religious affiliation
the person no longer ascribes to shik
and its people find that these points
are found in these opening verses of
admir
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala commands him
this is
number two
purify your deeds.
This is the second point he says
and abandon and disassociate yourself
from the worship of idols. This is the
third point. These three make up the
essence of Islam.
There's no such thing as a person who
accepts Islam but still worships other
gods
or associates unto Allah partners.
There is no such thing as a Muslim who
is Muslim by name but nonpracticing
meaning they have Islam in its teachings
has zero bearing on their lives.
This does not exist. This cannot exist.
This is a non-existent
idea that's in people's minds. In order
for a person's Islam to be valid, there
has to be some bearing, some semblance
of holistic obedience to Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. Even if the person makes
mistakes, even if the person sins, even
if the person that is expected. But a
person to say
and then move on with their life never
learning anything extra. That statement
having zero bearing on his life or her
life and their choices thereafter. This
is not considered to be a valid Islam.
And number three, disassociation from a
shik and its people. That a person
doesn't become Muslim and say, you know,
Islam is great and I personally am
Muslim. However, you know, this
idolatry or that idolatry is, you
know, also interesting. It's acceptable.
It's very it's some you know there's
many ways to Rome right many roads all
roads lead to Rome as they say or that a
person say generally holistically
speaking I love or this person says that
they love Hindus
those whom they've met and those whom
they have not met it's their Hinduism
that makes them love them this is a type
of shik
Remember here we are speaking about a
spiritual love. What is a spiritual
love? We as Muslims,
we have a spiritual love for all
Muslims.
Those whom we met and those whom we have
not met. They are all our brothers and
sisters whether we know them or not.
Their trait that makes them our brothers
and sisters is their Islam.
If a person were to have this affection
or this association with a religion
other than Islam in this way, this will
make a person's Islam invalid.
Because these are the three points when
Allah says abandon idols.
Abandon the worship of idols. Abandon
the holidays and celebrations of idols.
Abandon the superstitions of idols.
Abandon the people of idolatry. What did
Iraim say to his people?
He said, "We hereby disassociate
ourselves from you all and
that which you worship aside from
Allah." Notice the wording. The war, we
disassociate ourselves from you
and
those which you worship aside from
Allah.
Pharaoh's wife said,
"She made her dua, oh Allah, save me
from Pharaoh and his actions."
We don't have this idea that has been
heard by, you know, Muslims hear these
ideas sometimes, these poetic oneliners.
They catch a person's attention
and they sound correct but they are
incorrect. Such as hate the sin and not
the sinner.
This here tells us that there is a
difference between the action and the
person who commits that act. This is a
statement that is taken from
Christianity. This doesn't exist in the
Quran in the Sunnah.
There is an inherent connection
between the person and his actions.
That's why on the day of judgment what
will be weighed?
People's actions, people's deeds. And in
other verses, people themselves will be
weighed. In other verses, the scrolls of
a person's deeds will be weighed. Why?
Those all three of those are the same
thing.
When Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
that he is he will weigh a person
and in another verse he will weigh a
person's actions and in another verse he
will weigh the scrolls of a person's
actions. That's because they are all the
same thing. You cannot separate between
the person and the behavior. They are
innately connected.
And so these three points are the
definition of Islam.
And these three points are what the
prophet sallall.aii was sent to uphold
in himself and expound upon in his
da'wah. all of the rest of the Quran,
every other verse that was revealed to
him subsequent to these verses, every
following verse that was revealed to him
from the beginning of the Quran to the
end is an explanation of these opening
[Arabic recitation]